[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 40 of
GameSpot after-dark GameSpot's official
video game podcast I'm your host Jake
Decker and joining me this week is Lucy
James ie Kelly plaguey ah and Tamar
Hussain hi we have a special episode
planned as someone special for once we
decided we should maybe wait to record
until after the big news drops so we're
recording now on Thursday morning so we
can talk about the Xbox what is it 2020
is that what they were calling it I got
box showcase inside Xbox 2023 five eight
over two days directly yeah so we are
going to skip over what we've been
playing this week I don't think any of
us have really been playing anything too
exciting
see that's it and I feel like we've
talked about that game to death yeah and
and I was gonna talk about like Red Dead
Redemption to again which was like yeah
you know what that it's not not the
place for that so we're gonna go right
into this Xbox one x-bracing Xbox series
X sorry it's gonna happen but I mean I
guess we can just start off with like I
don't know general thoughts on the thing
like I don't know two more did X give it
to you oh my god X absolutely did not
give it to me I mean like I I I liked
the problem he has is we went in there
being told it was going to be a meaty
look at gameplay and instead of getting
that maybe partly it's our expectations
we got a quick cut through a bunch of
games now I don't want to devalue the
fact that they were all big new IPs and
a lot of them look really interesting
score looks amazing don't looks okay
bright memory infinite looks fine well
like we didn't get any any like really
meat he looks at gameplay
same for assassins like assassins was
the big ticket and it was I mean we saw
glimpses of it more than an actual like
his a you know 5-10 minutes look
gameplay so although nothing I came away
from it with no indication of what makes
the power of the Xbox Series X
interesting for gameplay which is a
shame yeah well I mean all the games
they pretty much all the games they
talked about right have that what do
they call it xbox obsolete like eight
times they said probably more than eight
times actually written this one trillion
times delivery or something oh all the
games for the most part have that which
is like cool but at the same time it's
like okay so then these games aren't
really showing us the true potential of
the series X because all these games are
also optimized for Xbox one X I don't
know exactly how it works on the other
it's like surely I mean surely you add
it and it gets you by the game it gets
added to your Xbox account maybe they
give you a code if you buy it on disk so
you can like lock it to your account and
so when use that account on your series
X it'll like work the thing that I think
they would have needed to really show
the power of this series X would be
comparisons in load times but then
that's difficult to do because then
you're essentially painting your current
console that you are still wanting
people to be buying because you're
having the excited Punk version come out
this summer that you're painting that in
a slightly negative light so I honestly
don't think we're gonna get that kind of
comparison until later in the year when
they're fully ramping up this showcase
this morning I think to play devil's
advocate in a way because like obviously
what they were promising wasn't great
but I think if you compare it to the
original Xbox one launch and like reveal
this is night and day and it kind of
just shows this great evolution of Xbox
as a company and yeah I think they got
the wording definitely wrong soon as I
saw that Assassin's Creed trailer and
there was still the widescreen borders I
was like
I guess if you're paying wants to if
you're paying blurred Studios millions
and millions to make your CGI trailer
you get the absolute most out of uh CGI
trailer but that was maybe I think that
big misstep from this presentation but
everything else like I think the humor
the hey here's this massive list of
every company that we're working with
that's really good that putting games
first I need to know more about Aaron
Greenberg's a camera and be fresh
recently has been getting so deep into
[ __ ] posting that I am really a big fan
of it when he first said it he's like
I've got the fastest most powerful
fridge in my kitchen - I didn't consider
it for a second I just thought he was
joking about the size and then I looked
and I finally looked and I was like oh I
see what they did there they did a
little little joke good work good work
highlight yeah yeah yeah I think like I
think what we expected was meaty
gameplay but what they gave us was a
bunch of new games which I think is like
super exciting I think if you'd like to
take a step back like Lucy said and
really think about it it's considerably
better than what they put in and and I
don't want to pit them against Sony but
we've seen what Sony did was their
approach where it was very technical and
a lot of people were like ok but what
about the games Microsoft have kind of
like you know curbed that discussion
very early by am showing off games and a
lot of them look really cool yeah and
and I that was I think one thing one
very positive thing I had walking away
from this was that there was a lot of
new IPs - I think the oh I mean like
you've got madden of course and you've
got dirt 5 we'll get into these later
and the vampire the vampire the
masquerade bloodlines which are sequels
but like most of the games they showed
off seem like you know pretty big budget
new IPs which is always my favorite part
about new generations and well a lot of
the new IPs that come out these new
games aren't the greatest it's still
really cool to see what sticks what
doesn't to see all these new ideas and
like watch people set like the new I
don't know I guess standard for next gen
it that was interesting I was exciting
Kelly what were your overall thoughts of
it yeah I mean not much different than
what we've already said I uh I mean it's
kind of hard to show off like visual
fidelity fidelity over stream I think so
that was also it's difficult to because
it depends on the the viewers like
internet quality so when you're talking
about like this is game play on series X
I'm not really getting that full effect
I was also watching on my phone so that
probably the only one that was playing
out 4k mixer and twitch weren't due in
4k oh not even a mixer
I was dreaming cuz I guess I were
watching it in bed so I like Greg was
watching it in the living room and
streaming and I don't know we haven't
reset our rooster in a while actually
just talked to my list I was like I was
watching it crushed and I was like ah
facts in there pal
yeah pretty much it wasn't like that's
on me I could have yeah got up but also
it was early I guess to bring up the
first game bright memory infinite which
they showed off that I looked at that
trailer after the fact that did a 4k
trailer and it looked way better than
what I saw on the stream and it looked
pretty impressive and especially
considering it's a game made by one
person right did I hear that correctly
knowing about for a little while and
it's been building some buzz and I think
the big news is it's coming to series X
but yeah it's an impressive product I
don't wanna call that product that's so
heartless it's an impressive game from
one person and really speaks to like how
much engine technology has come how far
has come and that one person can take an
inch in and and you know use assets
available and create something like this
I'm not saying like he's just copying
pasting or this person I don't know is
it's copying and pasting but like it's
for one person to do it is incredibly
impressive well first to look that good
is even more impressive yeah like the
weather effects in like the rain blowing
around was
super impressive that looks interesting
right it gave me titanfall vibes
honestly just seeing the wall running
and even the sight of God
I thought stifle - actually the way that
the would you call it
Pathfinder sort of from apex movement
yeah I read ugh that yeah I also I was
like interested in score and I thought
scorned I mean like you really see a lot
of swarm but I was like oh I like creepy
stuff hmm so schooling looks amazing -
about scorn so there was something that
was floating out from about 2016 that
people were sharing on Twitter after the
event I've never heard of it before I
think it yeah it showed up a car when it
showed up it was like a maybe a year ago
as well we showed up again it's like a
Metroidvania style game with a lot of
obviously heavily inspired by HR goggles
work so because of that it will look a
lot like alien to people and it's
designed by studio code developed by a
studio called ab so it's like some sort
of dreamlike world and there's like
loads of interconnected regions that you
can like explore in in a free-form way
like a Metroidvania would let you do and
then it's like unlocking skills and
weapons as you go along so the typical
Metroidvania format but within a HR
Giger style theme which sounds amazing
I was I mean this trailer was like what
10 past 8:00 this morning PT I was like
love to see that phallic symbolism Wow
and dripping in there having sex as well
in there I was surprised honestly and
then you got you got the yonex and
symbolism in there - mm-hmm which is a
word that I enjoy cuz nobody use knows
that word even though they know what
phallic means Yannick baby oh I know
it's just that it's the opposite other
one yeah it was interesting I was like
this isn't like for this is a lot for 8
a.m. but
I'm like here for it I think it speaks a
lot to I mean they've definitely
identified that their audience is gonna
be the older gamers who aren't gonna be
tuning into this to watch oh let's look
at Minecraft on the series XY they want
to see like what the hell's come in to
the next generation I find it weird to
hear next generation because in my head
it's still 2013 yeah yeah yeah well
given the current situation time is
actually going backwards so I guess to
move back a little bit after bright
memory infinitive a showed off the fifth
dirt game which I think I played dirt to
it didn't look all that different from
previous that like I was I wasn't
looking for dirt I was looking for filth
if you know I'm saying like I needed to
see the textures I need to see the car
and instead we just got I mean I'm sure
it's it looks it looks fun but I mean
I'm not your audience here yes I mean I
think it's interesting they've got Troy
and Nolan involved that was a revealer
wasn't see coming yeah I'm kind of sad
that they're just voicing like people I
kind of wasn't voicing like like that I
wanted them to voice the cause like to
rival cause that's not an executive
thing like it sound like they like
shoved a recording device in their in
their face filter recording their lines
but say this for us please we're like
have this we have this Xbox thing we
have to do they're like I'm excited to
be in codemasters new video game that's
like cool that's all it was like I'm
happy to be in
duh-duh 5-1 choice uncharted kart racing
yeah there we go
next thing we saw was course Rises won
this game looks interesting I think I
was more interested in it and bit until
I found out that it seems like a space
combat game and I was like I don't know
if I'm super into flying spaceships
around maybe there's more to it than
that
but the story seems interesting there
are a couple things I wanted to say
about this trailer first of all I loved
that she had the eyebrows lit this eager
lass
I wrestle it but also I like that this
game abides by the Cheever jizz rules of
spelling yes yes yeah yeah cuz I was
like service it took me a good amount of
time to be like oh I mean chorus no this
we I'm saying it now official GameSpot
standard is to call it chore this is now
in the style guide god that sounds like
a name
Elon Musk and crimes against all of them
I was like yep that's that's that's that
one tick tock many years from now but
like a story seems cool like she's some
sort of single-handed Savior for some
maybe all of the mankind or something
like that it sounded like that but then
expect his ships and then I was like oh
I guess I guess she saved everyone using
a ship cool yeah she reminded me the
first thing I thought it was Jack from
Mass Effect 2 which I have in the notes
here I saw it and I was like well I
could kind of see that I would be it for
that hmm I liked her tattoos they look
cool as well yeah mm-hmm design all
right so I've dedicated a lot of time to
talk about this next one Madden 21 I was
gonna say sadden 21 but no because I
have any sort of like a will towards it
just because my that's how my brain
works is fires bad puns the moment they
come in yeah I feel like well it's got
anything bad about this game well I
should have this podcast is people from
a country where they don't play this
sport and then people who don't like
sport I have tried to play mad in almost
every year um really I can yeah yeah I
yeah I tried nation no no no I by I by
Madden I get FIFA I play PES like Anna
each time I'm just like okay I know how
this plays because if I'm gonna write
about it at any point or if someone like
froze me an interview I want to be
prepared for it even if I don't if
even if I don't like but I always play
it get the function understanding of how
it works but it never sticks with me
Madden is the one I struggle well Madden
and the hockey games I'm just like I
don't I don't know the rules well enough
for hockey and like mad and I'm just
like this stop start nature of it I'm
like I like I don't mind watching
American football over the course of ten
years which is a match or whatever but
like playing games like I'm just I can't
run this place I don't know what he's
played mean don't understand what it is
I'm like I've watched the Super Bowl
I've seen the Chicago Bears good job I
watched a game with Greg a while ago and
it was what it was a really high scoring
game I think you got to like 40 odd
something points in oh yeah
yeah it was like a ridiculous game and I
was looking at ground Ozzy his American
football I was like this and you went no
absolutely not it was like this okay but
it seems like I saw I'm the game based
on this is based on Twitter rumblings of
people I follow who are into sports and
into games and they were like yep looks
like Madden this looks like an old woman
so nothing in there as far as I can tell
that's mind-blowing different they
haven't done a FIFA the journey for
Madden or any other other one something
I think they did yeah they did one I
remember trying to play one of those a
little while ago and being like good
yeah I like story mode for Madden that
addresses like head trauma I told my ass
that will be the one oh yeah God also
documentary from last year yeah within
the NFL know about the guy who killed
his interested hundred play that alone
but are there any cheerleading games
like action cheerleading game I'm not I
don't play that lollipop chainsaw the
only man the only football
game I've ever played with NFL Street -
and I like that because it was just like
Arkady and ridiculous but I don't think
I think they may have made a three once
and I didn't play it and and then they
became less interested in making those
kind of games play it so they'd stop
make him yeah I guess so I guess it's my
fault that just looking like other books
well Jackie's out so we got a can these
what I was like I just want to say when
I was like five I told my dad that I
wish he would cancel footballs like it's
lit like a rage like TV season and he
said that's not very nice how would you
feel if I said I wish they canceled
Nickelodeon and that's when I learned
empathy I mean he knew all these years
later you'd be you'd get what you want
fine anyway the next game on the list I
think one of the ones I'm most excited
for here is vampire the masquerade
bloodlines two big vibes from this
trailer I know like especially coming
from I think what they showed at e3
right it see it was very serious and
dark and this one had a very interesting
dark sense of humor to it well when I
first saw it I thought it was a wee
happy for you because it smiles the
darkness
because it's thoughts of open logo for
like darkness nose like no another band
I thought you know I thought was a new
darkness title cuz I saw the world of
darkness and it took me a few like a few
minutes to be oh no way this is vampire
the masquerade what are they doing with
that license man to figure out what
don't care we got didn't developer buy
it recently the the I thought I remember
reading day
yeah like the license to make video
games hmm before any but it was good I'm
so excited for the original yeah it's
hard to play these days but I love that
original one that was so good I reminded
me a kind of I treating like as if I was
in the TV show angel because it was just
like an LA like see
where's loads of vampires and societies
and that kind of stuff and you just
rolling around still worth playing if
you have you seen interviews at the I
think either the lead writer creative
director for that game know he looks
like the kind of person that would
writer-director game about vampires yeah
but like like the interview I saw he was
wearing like fingerless gloves and like
he was like all wearing all black and I
was like right he was very pale and I
was like it's like should make that
thing way if you're a developer working
on a camera interview have to dress in
theme with the game so you're like
interviewing a quality developer in like
full military regalia hey don't you have
the power to do that at GameSpot
tomorrow Kenya all right if you guys
want us to interview yeah I could yeah
listen cyberpunk if you want to stay
interview you you need to be half robot
Nomura you need to wear at least five
more belts I mean I think he's role in
be like yeah there he is the only honest
back again the next one call of the sea
which looks interesting it looks a lot
like a sea of thieves style game but it
looks like it's more story focused I was
shocked
yeah we're Bioshock to you like it's
like the all of that what you just said
but also like out a while so I feel like
there's gonna be a lot of games are like
our worlds like now so watch hmm
why wouldn't any vibes like following
this I don't know do you yeah I want to
see more of it because I felt like the
art style didn't match the narration
maybe that's a weird thing that like
only I would care about like it was like
dearest Henry and London like the art
was kind of like colourful and cartoony
yeah and I mean I know Pete there's a
lot of fatigue on like grim dark gritty
stuff but I like grim dark gritty stuff
so I was like where are the clouds but
in this one this one turned into the
shape of water because you saw the gia
amphibious kind of hands at the end so
maybe
go there okay no see that that's all I
need it now I'm more invested yeah way
to go on selling that Lucy thank you
yeah you did it bad in the Train
by shark means fire watch meets the
shape of words
fabious hands hands I couldn't think of
the webbing would you call that wedding
yeah hands weapon for your pleasure
anyway the ascent a top-down cyberpunk
shooter Oh
cyberpunk eNOS listen yeah I'm like this
but there's only room for one cyberpunk
in my heart right now and we all know
which one that one is but this looks
cool I think this looks cool I was
trying to looked stylistically it looked
really cool but I think that the
top-down stuff kind of lost me I was
like I don't know if I want it yeah like
intro like cinematic sequences I was
like okay aliens
cyberpunk and then the top-down stuff I
was kind of like not as jazzed about
yeah I don't know if anyone played
ruiner but that was a top-down cyberpunk
shooter that was really good
so looking at that like obviously look
like two different games different
styles and all that kind of stuff but I
don't know I was like I think I got my
filled with ruiner
I'd be more I don't know he had top down
didn't do it for me I rarely played
top-down games to be honest but I mean I
might as well come to game path so I'm
not saying that I know that or anything
but like I imagine a lot of these titles
will come to pass at some point yeah
nobody played too much much TV back in
the day I love me some top-down so I
think that's why I'm like alright
alright next up here is the medium the
horror game from blooper team the ones
who did observer observer observer and
in Blair Witch did you guys play
observer and/or Blair Witch I play
observe
layers of fear but not glare which okay
I didn't play observer but I played
Blair which which I which I thought was
good I really liked it the one with the
dog companion rate yeah the one with the
dog companion and they make named our
studio Bluebird makes horror games yeah
they they they make really cool games
though so I'm interested in seeing so we
we actually have an interview with
developers from Bluebird team up on our
site it's conducted by Steve watts and
they kind of spoke about what they would
so this is the game that they had the
idea for they could they say in 2012 but
they said they couldn't make it because
the tech wasn't there in place until now
everyone says that it's like yeah the
classic day one how do we make our game
look cool but they seem to be very into
the the kind of tech to the point where
in our interview they mentioned that
they have something in their game that
they pretty much described as a
revolutionary to the point where they're
patenting it so they wouldn't talk to us
about it but they all like we're not
there already to talk about it and they
kind of teased it in in the actual
interview they do during the inside Xbox
so I'm intrigued to see what that is at
the very least basically I make yes yeah
keep an eye on that our money trust me
but you know office I'm there all day
but like at the very least they make
interesting narrative Lee themed games
they talk about it in in our interview
but they always use horror like most
horror does like that the mark of good
horror is exploring something through
the lens of horror and they do that
really well whether that's like you know
feelings of isolation or like loss or
you know a normal working day life and
how that is explored and through
thriller / horror theme so I'm excited
to see where they got yeah I think
that's why I enjoyed Blair Witch as much
as I did was just because it didn't feel
like a like a Blair Witch game could
have easily just been a derivative campy
horror game but they actually tried to
tell a story and do something
interesting with it so I'm excited to
see whatever whatever they have planned
next I kinda want to go back and play
observer two because I remember hearing
a lot of good things about that game
I think that is on game pass yeah I
think it is yeah so I I enjoyed that
quite a bit
I'll have to check that excited at the
start of the medium because I thought it
was gonna be a sad mom game like the
counterpart to sad dad games and I was
like oh we're finally getting our sad
mom game what's the sad lost of us is
pitcher is fine nothing is a low-key sad
dad gamers we chose dad game male guess
all it this is kind of sad dad game good
big boss
right dead in a way it's like a spy [ __ ]
to sign goes between like sad dad angry
dad oh why shock infinite is Peter
passion Bioshock Infinite's 100% like
Skybound sad dead so in conclusion
there's lots of sad games and we love
many of those sad dad games but I was
like oh man said mom games mom's time to
shine but it cuz it started with an
ultrasound and I was like woah and but I
am also into the horror yeah we haven't
haven't technically that last cooking
mama game is the sad mom game very good
Scarlett Nexus anime game and you Kelly
let's do this
proper shy I kid I kid
it looks like it looks like what was
that last anime Dark Souls games that he
made code vein vein it looks like they
very quickly prepared from Cobain and
something else yeah yeah I did get that
vibe I that this is another one where
the start of the trailer I was like okay
okay because it had these like flower
monsters no yeah okay that's pretty cool
and then they hit me with the like they
couldn't be hurt
until now and I was like alright and the
characters voice as well like it really
stuck out as being awkward the now place
it was one that I I wish they had gone
with the Japanese dub just because I
feel like it would have been less of a
jarring transition from the like drama
of the intro to that trailer too like
the Shonan like young boy voice like
teenage boy voice of the protagonist and
I think maybe because the audience for
this isn't Japanese speaking a Japanese
voice over would have been a little bit
easier but then just because it was in
Japanese so maybe that was maybe there
was just bandai's decision and not
Xboxes yeah maybe possibly I mean like
the thing uh I mean I'm definitely gonna
keep an eye on it because anime game but
like like the the telekinesis side of it
whenever games do like physics based
telekinesis around combat I'm always
into it like ever since I ops and and
like more recent stuff as well like
control has a bit but love it actually
I love that stuff so I'm definitely
keeping eye on it but like it very much
like Timmy I was like this looks kind of
code veiny to me and code veiny let me
down in a big way so yeah well we
mentioned it before but Yakuza Yakuza
like a dragon about this is why
everyone's here for a see this is what I
showed up for a Wii
you know what I assume we're allowed to
talk about it but when we went to Atlas
last year to shoot something for persona
we sat down with the devs and they
played a bunch of like a dragon yeah and
that game is that [ __ ] I love it
the demo came out so yeah we could so
it's like yeah the conceit is like each
of the main character he yeah it's yeah
each year he is a huge Dragon Quest fan
and he's like caught up in dragon
well like in his mind that's why all the
combat plays out in turn based mode
because in his it's actually real time
in real life but in his mind he sees it
as turn-based because he saw into Dragon
Quest Dragon Quest exists exists in that
universe and the the thing that they
show like there's a early quest that we
did was pulling that baseball bat out of
sword from the stone style kind of thing
and then like there's one part where we
went into a store and you could buy was
it a vibrator yeah I think was a
vibrator from like from like the donkey
okay and use that as a weapon and let
you buy like a dildo and use that as
well and like they they are really
leaning into like the absurd I think
what they're doing is like twice when
they slow it down and make it turn-based
they're leaning intellect the absurd
special moves there's one part where we
saw what he like calls in an orbital
strike from a satellite using his phone
on and like one random enemy and it's
ridiculous but that trailer like I think
the thing that's been for a lot of
yuppies our fans they've been trying to
figure out where its position because
obviously curious stories ended but it
looks like he will be around because
they showed Maji mind that yeah I'm
currently replaying the echoes of Syria
so I'm very in Yakuza mode so I'm
excited for that when I went to I'm
gonna finish so I've done Final Fantasy
I'm gonna finish royal persona 5 and
then I'm going to yoga zero this is how
I'm spending my isolation Yakuza zero
has a quest where you have to teach a
fake Michael Jackson how to moonwalk and
it's amazing it's a cruise named miracle
Johnson so yes good oh my God we're all
too excited about yeah I want to know
what the the conversation was like with
Square Enix and they're like hey so we
want to have Dragon Quest in this game
but also like not like how that must
have been interesting
I can't really we did ask about them and
I remember was everyone just looking at
each other shifty eyed so there's
nothing I can say about that I think
they know likely sorry Kelly I was gonna
say no likelihood I think they're
working that deal out okay I definitely
have seen an anime where Dragon Quest
existed in the anime and it was like
super not it was erased which I really
like the ending but the rest is just
good but um they that way it was set in
the 80s they were talking my Dragon
Quest all the time so I'm like I don't
know maybe it's enough of a institution
that that deal isn't as hard as we do
like like Family Mart in Japan had like
a whole Dragon Quest promotion and the
like the the Family Mart doors instead
of playing their normal jingle played
Dragon Quest music like last year mm-hmm
so I I don't know maybe it's it's an old
enough franchise that it's like we're
storied yeah there's a TV series called
I think it's good the hero Yoshihiko and
the demons castle
I think it's called lucky you sure
you're sure he Co which is it's a parody
series of Dragon Quest that is
absolutely phenomenal like even if you
don't care about Dragon Quest and you
just know JRPGs you should watch that
because it is hilarious like so good
so I think and this the first enemies
they see is a slime in that in that
series so I think the square-enix is
fairly fast and loose with Dragon Quest
licences yeah gonna be your first yeah
well I've played zero I couldn't get
into it I played one couldn't get into
it
I played judgment which I guess is in
Yakuza and I couldn't get into it I'm
gonna try it but I don't know if it'll
be my thing we'll see what I've seen I'm
really excited for and I do love how
they announced this by like showing it
last April first as an April Fool's joke
and everyone be like wait that'd
actually be kind of cool and they're
like good because we're making it I just
want to say anyone from rgg studio is
watching for whatever reason please make
the Cabaret club minigame into a mobile
game I would pay real money I would
operate like it's a real gotcha game I
just want that I hope it's in like a
dragon I love the Cabaret cloche it's so
every club is unreal that's why I'm kind
of replaying it because I want to get
more cabaret stuff done and like even if
there's like the RC car racing it
shouldn't be as fun as it is but like
it's it's weirdly obsessive like all the
other that karaoke as well watching Q
you do karaoke for hours on end there's
nothing else like in gaming anyway
lastly they wrapped up with Assassin's
Creed of all holla some hot gameplay oh
wait we missed we missed extinction was
it sick oh you didn't a second
extinction reclaim earth but I thought
was turrican minute more than o Tarak
that's what I meant to put in that Dino
Crisis yeah that's what it looks like
cool I mean I saw a really good tweet
where it's like Oh doing what [ __ ] what
[ __ ] I won't know something I was like
yeah yeah okay I feel like people have
been wanting a new turret
Tarak for a long time and and everyone's
like yeah I just want to like fight
dinosaurs in a first-person shooter game
and then after seeing that I was like I
don't actually want that but I don't
know I'll play it it looks fun I just I
don't know I guess I just didn't quite
get why people really wanted it a new
turret game wasn't the switch or
something and it was like bad was an
agenda
didn't they port turret to switch or
something recently I was bad yeah what
or impellers rough I mean I think that
gaming by modern standards is just bad
like yeah it wasn't me I'm gonna be real
it wasn't great back in the day either
yeah I I just that trailer like I was
asleep I don't want to hurt these
creatures like it just I don't know if
it was like I watching that trailer I
was like why am i okay we shooting
people but not dinosaurs I should
examine that that's that's the only
takeaway I have from this well
Assassin's Creed Valhalla
it was a short game yeah it wasn't very
much gameplay in the traditional sense
but continues to look cool I fully
expected from the way they were talking
about it I was expecting to see like a
rate or something like a full 510 minute
demo at the end in Assassin's Creed
Valhalla you play as a vault John
Marshall that's what we wanted oh we do
that but you've yourselves gotta just be
holding on to all that stuff for their
stream whenever that happens it like
yeah we're gonna save the good stuff
which I understand but at the same time
considering they market it as game play
it's kind of like well you know
technically I guess you should yeah
Twitter right now is like not happy
gameplay it's just tried doing bites up
I think a lot of people are pissed
games are yeah I at the same time it's
like I get being kind of annoyed that
they didn't show gameplay but it's like
it's an assassin's Creed game right like
they're gonna show gameplay soon it's
gonna come out before the end of the
year like you'll play it for a month or
two and then you'll move on and think
about the next set of greed like it's
fine it's fine
gameplay will be there don't worry and
also like you have to take into account
that people were doing all like a lot of
that final stuff from home and you know
that's harder to do so it's like I don't
know I feel like getting mad is what
like chill out yeah like it's it's it's
funny to dunk on like it's clearly just
Microsoft and Ubisoft didn't really
think about it they were like oh yeah
this is gameplay and they didn't realize
it would be a bit of a backlash cuz it's
like I don't know a couple nature shots
moving slowly that's just kind of like
okay yeah I mean I'm still really pumped
to that game I think Greg was playing
Odyssey again yesterday and I was like
dip my toe back in but yeah
give us a 20-minute like I I imagine
probably it's just not ready and they
just didn't want to put unfinished stuff
up on a presentation with as many eyes
on it as this but yeah I I'm curious to
see cuz normally with the past couple
Assassin's Creed's
at e3 we've had like an hour-long
hands-on time with them so I imagine at
some point this summer maybe a little
later they'll show like an extended
livestream of gameplay in that game or
maybe they'll do a um they play it with
Google's stadia I'm not saying that to
be facetious about Google stadia but if
you remember the first time they were
testing that you could just play Odyssey
yeah that could be an interesting way to
deliver hands on his demo or something
yeah that'd be pretty cool um but also
it would be on Google Stadium so yeah
which I don't think I would buy in the
stadia to play well it's Assassin's
Creed demo it's free yeah I still need a
control no I guess I don't need a
control but don't you need a chromecast
if you want to play it on TV okay but if
you wanted to play it like I guess I
couldn't make it work but I probably
want it yeah anyway let's move on to
listener questions we've got a couple
here Kelly you want to take the first
one
sure remember that you can email us at
after our podcast 18 spot comm to ask
questions or you can join the diskless
this first one is I've just rolled on
it's from Isaiah Perez from Pennsylvania
hey guys I love the podcast and I've
been listening secretly it works since
the first episode I sent it a few
questions but I'm sure you all get a lot
of questions so I'm not too bound to my
question didn't get answered
I've been working my on my back lock
between Animal Crossing apex and modern
warfare which is fun titanfall 2 and wow
what a game but week later I beat The
Last of Us and I can't wait for the new
game to grace us in June but Jake help
me out here where can I find out more
about the world and lore of the Last of
Us I fell in love with the game and it
took me so damn long to finally play and
beat it I want to learn more about
everything I can without spoiling myself
for the next game
I'm needed a whole list of words related
to the game but I do want to find out
about the first game and the world of
the game bills anyways sorry to ramble
you guys are great
thanks for continually bringing us
content through the podcast and say I
love it all keep it up I'm looking
forward to all the content I don't have
a great answer for this but I just
wanted to include it because he's
written in a couple times and I just
wanted to get it in and said some very
nice things but there isn't a whole lot
of law out there for the last visits
least that at least that I'm aware of
definitely play left behind if you
haven't it should be included if you
played it on ps4 and there's a comic
series - I think it's like a four-part
comic series that documents before I
actually even read it but I think it's
before left behind or it's right after
left - one of the two Evans working on a
video about like the the story so far
but he's gone super in-depth like he's
read all of the in-game letters and all
the environmental storytelling he's
gonna go in depth I had to ask him texts
and the deadline on cueing it because it
was so long gonna be able to read this
in one day one of my favorite I mean the
Lord last of us is a ish in the sewers I
think that storyline is super
interesting and super like it's welcome
it's self-contained within that and so
yeah
Evans piece definitely the comic book
like Jake said I think there's an all
right that might there is an art book I
don't know if it's it does I think
there's some like concept art of areas
that weren't explored in the game like I
think there's I think there's concept
art of like San Francisco in there I
used to have it I should try to order
another one and then the other thing I
would say too is it's not really lore
but I would recommend checking out
grounded which is a documentary about
the making of the Last of Us yeah I
thought was super fascinating like
you're not gonna learn a whole lot more
about the world that you don't know but
it's still cool just to see their
process and I think they even talked
about how they announced that game which
was I thought pretty interesting at the
time so yeah tomato but firmly check
those out read about cordyceps I have a
great time yeah watch the day
for documentary yeah don't read the
comments on anything yeah I had I had
that I had this boat for me I I saw
something I'm not gonna say it obviously
I saw something and I don't know if
someone just made it up to mess of
people hi someone replied to a
demolition man to eat was just the
spoiler and I was like to see a
demolition man exactly no hates it they
don't know it was a mistake yeah anyway
next question is from Dede on the
discord server if you want to send us
questions the discord server or just
hang out we got a bunch of people there
talking about video games movies TV
shows comics all sorts of things you can
do many of us and we'll get you in there
but anyway this one's from deviousness
except for Callie he says hi guys what
is a good first trailer should it
mislead you in order to avoid spoilers
should it be crystal clear about what it
is should it have gay a game play be
necessary or CG the reason I included
this is because I actually had a really
good one because I've been playing Red
Dead Redemption too and I think the
trailer for the teaser trailer for Red
Dead Redemption 2 released in 2016 was
really good because it teased a lot of
the story of the game it showed what the
game was gonna look like and rewatching
it after play after having played
through the game just give gives me
chills every time like I still watch
that trailer because that line at the
end like you got a run and you got in
don't look back is is is good tell yeah
I know I was gonna actually say Red Dead
1 had I don't know if it was the first
trailer though but I think all of the
trailers were really good because they
started off with like a grand story
trailer and then they went into the
101's which was like in Red Dead
Redemption
I think the Mass Effect 3 trailer like
take back earth was pretty good but that
was a CGI one and so that was like I
would obviously prefer to have like in
engine gameplay stuff but I think as far
as a tone setter that was a good trailer
looking back at old trailers now is kind
of wild because some of them just
I doubt spoil like big person turns from
games Oh regional original BioShock
trailer is another one where it's a
really good tone piece that sooner he
gets like it's like drilled through his
hand yeah yeah that's really good
because it's like you don't get any
sense of the actual story of the game
but you get introduced to the key
characters like you see a Big Daddy you
see little sista you see rapture right
and that's really good to me I think oh
sorry to me I think tone setting is the
most important like personally like I'm
no marketing major there's plenty of
stuff that I'm probably not thinking of
but I really like so like scoring for
example I liked that Sporn
trailer gameplay trailer we got today
because it gave me a sense of that world
and didn't sail like I didn't you didn't
heed to say anything to get a sense of
kind of what was going on or what like
the the overall name of that game is and
I really like that I'm the kind of
person I remember tone and emotion
better than actual plot details a lot of
the time so me to me I like getting a
taste of that in a first trailer just to
be like oh is this something I'm gonna
be interested in um somatically and then
when gameplay comes be like oh that's
not really my kind of gameplay but maybe
I'll give it a shot anyway or oh I love
this game player like I'm all in on this
I think Batman series has had some
amazing trailers I think the best of the
bunch one I like and it's more like
again tone and like cinematic quality
but I think come see he had that song
like shortchange hero which was amazing
and it's just like playing to the Sun -
like Batman fighting a bunch of enemies
Borderlands 2 as well yeah yeah but I
think Batman did it way better oh yeah
or you still were there
but of the oval the Batman games I think
Arkham origins has the best trailer the
CG one where it's young Bruce Wayne and
his mum and dad's funeral but you can
like he's in between what presumably is
Alfred and someone else and it's like
slowly zooming out from him and it's
intercutting like various moments for
his life that you see him at school
getting beaten up and you see him
training or the League of Shadows if I
remember correctly and it's like his
career up until he reaches becoming
Batman but all through the eyes of a boy
who's just lost his parents and it's
like super super good as a trailer it
looks really really good I think it's
one of the trailer was so good on an
episode of fat man versus Batman Kevin
Smith like talked about it and in that
episode turned it into an entire TV
series like it has so much potential in
that one trailer that he liked fleshed
out a full TV series of like young Bruce
Wayne like a school Academy trying to
you know deal with the the realities of
being a kid in school but also secretly
working his way to training to become
Batman in the future and I remember
hearing the pitch and being like that is
incredible I'd love to see that but like
just speaks to how much was in that
trailer and how effective it was nice
Lucy do you wanna take the last question
here this is a two-parter and it's from
two people
I think Jiggs asks the first part and
then Daniel Moreno added to it what
games you haven't played or not
interested in but your colleagues or
even everyone else in general plays
praise flash love it so much and which
games made you drastically change your
mind about them for the better after
finally giving them a try
I went to this question before and that
like I wish I knew more about Final
Fantasy 14 but they're releasing that
big patch in July I think it is so I can
finally dip my toe into it then and not
have to deal with all the crap stuff
that everyone hates from the base game
what game that I changed my mind about
after finally giving a try for me for
that second part for a game that I
change my mind about was Dishonored when
I saw the original pitch and trailers
for
that I wasn't super into it like the
world seemed cool but I don't know I
just didn't really do it for me and then
a couple months after it came out I was
like alright this game got really good
reviews I should give it a try and I
ended up well I tried to get all the
achievements but the the no-kill run
achievement didn't pop so I was a it's
it's kind of [ __ ] yeah you know I'll
check and if you leave like a body near
some water the tide will come in and
drown the body and you're dead yeah I
really enjoyed it though that's a game
that I definitely flipped on and you
know played dishonored to day one played
the DLC and stuff and really enjoy that
game overall mine my kingdom for at
least one and three the game that I
drastically changed my mind about was
overwatch because I hated the beer oh
really
well no no because I played it on
PlayStation and I picked tracer I
remember the first map was Hollywood
that I played on and I picked tracer and
I played there and I was like oh I'm
terrible at this I immediately hate it I
don't get it and then played on PC with
you guys I was like oh I mean I was
obsessed with that beer on PC oh my god
my one was a surprisingly Mass Effect
like the first Mass Effect when it came
out I really struggled with it and like
it turns out all it took for me to
really love it was crippling depression
but I like got into like this phase
where I just shot myself away and like
lived in darkness like literal like
blacked out my windows and and like
really threw myself into it and I think
I played it the first stretch I played
for was maybe 19 hours and then and then
just like kept playing that game and
once it clicked it really clicked for me
and I got obsessed with it but that
first game it has this like quirks and
it has its like weird like design
elements I think that's what I bounced
off initially and then when I came back
to it the kind of vibe and the story and
the characterization clicked a bit and I
think that's what pulled me in and
through it
how about you Kelly um I would say I
want to try blood-borne yeah you've
never played it but here's Tara talk
about it all the time
and it sounds like something I really
need to play map my project is currently
playing any absolutely sucks essay a
book and then a game that I changed my
mind about was death stranding I
couldn't give less of a [ __ ] about that
game but I decided to review it because
and I ended up loving it and thought it
was great
cool well I think that's a good spot to
end episode 40 of GameSpot after dark
thank you so much for tuning in and
we'll be back next week and we'll talk
about what we've been playing and all
the new news but thank you so much for
tuning in and remember if you want to
join our discord shoot any of us a
message on Twitter just don't send us
lots of uh spoilers unfortunately oh god
anyway Kali where can people find you
you can find me on twitter at inky
tojiko i nky DOJ I can't pay out Lucy
I'm at Lucy James games and for I am at
my age and you can find me at Jacob deck
and we'll see y'all next week
[Music]
you
[Music]